[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to sonic central my
name is mitch and i'm here with the
zookasan
we're looking at all the upcoming
excitement in the world welcome everyone
last year we celebrated the 20th
anniversary of everyone's favorite blue
hedgehog
in april we saw the incredible success
of sonic hedgehog 2 which opened as the
number one movie globally and once again
we
the games that defined a generation roll
back to the games that started it all
with sonic origins a new collection
including the definitive editions of
four iconic sonic titles
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fully remastered and redefined
experience all sonic origins has to
offer coming this month on june 23rd
celebrate sonic central in sonic speed
simulator on roblox
introducing the new chemical plant where
eggman has kidnapped the electric chow
and is using their life force to power
up metal sonic
exclusively for sonic central unlock amy
ciao using a designated code
free the electric chow and reprogram
metal sonic
join the fight against eggman on june
11th
this summer unlock special movie themed
characters from sonic the hedgehog 2 in
both sonic forces and sonic dash
in november super shadow is joining the
battle
this halloween watch out from a phyllis
the dark
show off your greatest achievements with
player banners
and welcome sir percival in sonic dash
and also in sonic dash plus on apple
arcade
the new netflix animated series sonic
prime is coming soon
here is a sneak peek of our new show for
our ultimate fans watching sonic central
[Music]
[Music]
uh
next please welcome the voice of sonic
from the sonic movie with a sneak peek
of sonic the hedgehog 2 on blu-ray and
digital
let's go
hey everybody ben schwartz here i am the
voice of sonic the hedgehog please hold
your applause please check out the home
entertainment release of my movie sonic
2.
beyond it being another great adventure
for sonic this time with some new
friends let's do this
yeah it is loaded with a ton of great
extras
it's got deleted scenes soon what did
you put in the coffee
can you hitler hilarious bloopers
he had beans in his hair tons of fun
moments from behind the scenes on set
and to top it off an exclusive animated
short which takes place right after the
events sonic 2 voiced by yours truly ben
schwartz let's see how fast
so do me a favor put down that chili dog
and take a look
right now or soon similar tuna
this year we have exciting products from
around the world
straight from angel island is an all-new
knuckles-inspired g-fuel available this
summer
go toe-to-toe with dr eggman with the
eggmobile battle set destroy that
meddlesome hedgehog with five
configurations straight from the games
available this fall from jakks pacific
level up your xbox gaming experience
with this sonic the hedgehog wireless
controller and quick charging stand by
razer
available this summer
more art introduces beautiful new art
handmade silk screen prints are a
celebration of the sonic timeline as he
races towards the future
introducing hype and sonic the hedgehog
capsule collection
featuring energetic designs inspired by
the high octane speedster
check out the upcoming collectibles
first four figures resin statues of amy
rose and miles tales prower
have fun on the go sonic tails and
knuckles are now available as pez
dispensers
showcase your controller or just have a
place to rest it in between gaming
check out the newest cable guy
controller holder
[Music]
retro gaming enthusiasts and sonic fans
find these iconic early 90s aesthetic
inspired statues of the blue blur
from japan is a special sonic soft vinyl
figure standing six inches tall
welcome this high speed hedgehog to your
room
the music continues stay tuned for the
return of the sonic the hedgehog
symphony
relive the magic of the sonic 30th
anniversary symphony concert live and in
person
watch iconic moments from sonic's
history come to life on the big screen
alongside a full symphony orchestra
with a few new surprises in store
[Applause]
tour dates and info coming soon
fall guys is going free to play on all
platforms on june 21st
with an all-new sonic collaboration
coming to fall guys in august 2022
come play as knuckles sonic and tails
[Music]
to celebrate sonic frontiers we are
excited to present a sneak peek of a new
animated special
featuring knuckles and taking place
before the events of the game we hope
you enjoy this exclusive first look
we look forward to sharing the entire
short later this year prior to the
release of sonic frontiers
[Music]
[Music]
hey sonic fans want to see more of sonic
frontiers then be sure to visit ign.com
right now and all june long because
sonic frontiers is the ign first cover
story you can watch the world exclusive
gameplay reveal right now as well as the
first ever hands-on preview with more
coming later in the month including
interviews with the sonic frontiers
development team and more you gotta go
best to ign
sonic frontiers is on its way there's
more details to come so be sure to
follow us on the official social
channels in the video description below
thank you for tuning in to sonic central
[Music]